welcome to my Christian server dude how
was that corrupt me bro hello and
welcome to PlayStation grenade minecraft
is trending once again everywhere I look
there's minecraft and that's fine and
all but the thing is I've never actually
played minecraft before well today that
changes the biggest note in Minecraft
history is here here's the thing let's
make something different to everyone
else as I've said I'm a complete novice
I have no idea what I'm doing and that's
where you guys come in the only tips and
tricks I can read are the ones you leave
in the comments below can you guys turn
me into a Minecraft god I've decided to
play the Java version of the game
because I'm told we can mod it to far
more than the ps4 version so today we
are PC grenade
if we hit 1000 likes we will make
episode 2 so if you like watching me
suffer remember you're completely in
charge of this so here we go hello come
buddy bit of Welsh there ok create new
world what do you want to call our world
you know what I'm going to go with a
good old [ __ ] Nath you likey yeah ok
survival let's just do this let's go
ok minecraft this is minecraft I'm
already a pro player craft wooden planks
the recipe book can help ok
Ella needs me hey everybody welcome to
my Christian server right minecraft what
the heck is that in the boss my arm it's
my arm ok
sheep are they hostile what the heck
ok they're destroying the world I've
seen enough minecraft videos to know did
you sponge things to start today and it
floats ok no such thing as gravity got
it got it minecraft thank you very much
can I use them how you can use different
things to hit different things I'm
learning I know this will take a long
time and I appreciate your um
patience and perseverance here but we
will get there
I am learning how to Minecraft ten years
after everybody else so okay remember
you're in charge of my playthrough where
I go what I do how I play thinks it's
all up to you of course this first
episode is made just understanding the
bare minimum the basics of what's going
on here
okay so I've got a little character
[Music]
that's the greatest bit of Minecraft so
far right awkward I've seen people just
just saw Chuck think oh I've made of
blanks I think you do I have to do this
by hand this takes a long time there
must be a quicker way of doing that okay
what do we do
what's that and the dragon dragon I know
all about those it's gone beat the crap
out of it
[Music]
and the you is insane temps fighting
skill
[Music]
oxygen that was my first battle with an
ender dragon
okay I know it's not an ender dragon all
right I've just tried to figure crap out
I've gotta fight a bit I've already
played like six minutes or something but
this is so much fun this is so much fun
I get why people are into this I really
do and we haven't even got into the
crafting element yet how do I craft
stuff why have I got a spleen don't
question it
no I'm sure I've seen people like make
make it a crafting table if we put
putting four things here what am I
missing
why am I an idiot I told you I'm the
worst person in the world all right I
don't know then you do that
[Applause]
my gosh I am the master of the Minecraft
pretty pretty yeah
yes I am the greatest minecraft player
ever live okay I'm getting it I'm
getting it slowly I know this is going
to take a while what do i how do I use
you ah there we go okay so these are
other things we can build and build a
song I can build a pickaxe okay so you
put three you put a couple of sticks and
then three of the birch things go to the
top and then do I just grab it oh boys
will get some spurt do I have to take
everything down ah you can just click
okay right I'm getting it and we can
drop those in then then I've got a start
okay we need to use this sword dhu did
it did it did it did it did why am i
singing legend of zelda did did it did
it in what the heck is that
what's that oh it's his backside
[Music]
half a human being
hey dude you might lunch messed him up
this is my world I really do like this I
can see why this took over the world
this game seems a lot of fun new recipes
unlock check your recipe book I will do
but we need to build a house now hey yo
ender dragons we mess you up so yeah I
want to get to the real ender dragons of
course I've been making this up as I go
along I want to know what the real ender
dragon is that's going to be probably
our 10th episode because I'm such an
idiot
do you that's taking longer why is that
taking longer than punching now take you
far too long what am I missing
an axe my axe right so I presume axes
are made to knock down trees
okay this is quite quick right we're
going to build a house it's going to be
the greatest house you've ever seen and
completely lying it's going to be a
Shack and it's going to be terrible but
it's going to be a son of a birch so I'm
told this mod so we can make the water
look more like water or we can add
shaders can you point me in the right
direction to get some good ones please
I'd like that
I'd like that a lot okay our house is
going to be in the lake oh whoops okay
didn't mean to do that
didn't mean I'm new okay I'm new just
give me time to understand what's going
on our first shed house in the lake it's
a nice what the hell is that noise what
the hell is that noise
[Music]
what is that a zombie in the middle of
the day RI b sh haha alright come on
bring it bring it I can mess you up I
have a wooden sword come at me bro
you're not very good in water are you
come on D okay I can even change this is
so easy
hi I'm Adam welcome to played PC grenade
welcome to PC grenade today we are a
smashing zombies in the face yes damn I
love this already right getting
nighttime I'm told nighttime is a bad
time I presume we get more of those
zombies at night okay and I'll work on
the house I'll work on the house
we need montage music and I'll work on
the house
[Music]
[Music]
I know it's not a masterpiece but well
with me I'm going to use tip to
different types of wood and we'll get
there slowly but surely and we'll build
this into our proper little lovely
little shack
[Music]
and wallah john marston eat your heart
out
okay we need a door how do you make
doors just put your hole and hope for
the best back over to my crafting table
let's go put a door on you [ __ ]
what do you how do you do this hey I've
made a how do you get in how did you get
into that thing like that I get it I get
it I get it let me [ __ ] leg coming sign
let's make a sign yeah our first sign I
know what it has to read you ready it's
Plunket there
our first time must read I'm not dead
yet famous last words
yeah there we go day what I'm not dead
yet this is good we've got three hearts
of hell how'd she get your hearts back
is that by sleeping so we do need a bed
so for a bed we need wool so we need to
beat the sheep to death let's go beat a
sheep to death just as it's getting dark
this is a good idea something yeah it's
deep around here
right which sheep do we get the black
one or the brown one what kind of bed do
we want do you want to be brown so the
stains are covers dude you're my first
victim I do apologize can you tell me
where the bar is oh thank you
all your bar was pretty good but the
heck is ice another zombie sheep do you
get hurt by the zombie
I'll save you sheep the zombie won't get
you let's do this bro just two hits and
I'm dead brains okay I didn't expect at
night this to become a bloomin zombie
fest
okay I said we'd stop when I died first
so this sign is completely pointless now
day one not dead yet lies lies where's
our stuff where's our stuff is it on my
dead body right we're just gonna go back
we're gonna mess that zombie up and we
are taking back everything we own those
are our things our supplies that's our
livelihood at stake there right
zombie dude come over here we'll give
you the runaround because we know how to
do this is quite freaky all this at
nighttime you know what the hell was
that what the heck is that work was a
spider
describe everything everything we grab
and we run we run his kid I just brought
my own leg jumping sister still chasing
me still chasing me still chasing me
just stay calm it's only minecraft that
is suddenly micro still come but he's
still coming you just run we're going to
go back home back home back to safety
run you little ass off get it in
Minecraft we've learned something today
we just run we just run for our lives
and hope that the spiders aren't as
quick as I can be from parkour I'm too
stressed just run run run come on come
on we are not dying twice there what the
heck skeleton skeleton with a bone
bloody arrow what kind of game is this
just keep going so minecraft I wasn't
expecting this I was I'm actually
sweating why am i sweating at Minecraft
who told me the Knights would Resident
Evil 2 this was stressful as hell okay
as you can tell I'm an idiot I need you
to help me how do i improve what should
I concentrate on what should I make over
to you guys
put down in the comments what you think
we should do next I will do anything you
tell me and I'll get your comments on
screen - thanks for your time episode 2
coming very soon if you want it I'm Adam
from PlayStation and PC grenade cutsies
suit spirit pleasure
you